ich will dass sie nicht
das ist köln die einwohner lieben ihre
stadt
was sie nicht leiden können sind die
vielen verkehrsstaus hier fahren züge
busse schiffe und sogar ein seilbahn
team süd wird irgendwo in köln
ausgesetzt und die drei sind nicht
allein in der stadt team nord startet an
einer anderen stelle bei der heutigen
aufgabe treten beide teams gegeneinander
an
benutzt auf dem weg zum kölner dom mehr
fortbewegungsmittel als das andere team
doch köln liegt am rhein
der fluss ist die erste hürde
ganz schnell hat team süd die ersten
sechs fortbewegungsmittel genutzt
darunter ist auch dieser traktor der
jonas ein paar meter mitnimmt und ein
linienbus
das ist zwar laut straßenverkehrsordnung
verboten aber was macht man nicht alles
für ein ticket nach berlin
nach kurzem zögern darf christina auf
das pferd steigen
das ist das nächste fortbewegungsmittel
von team süd danach nehmen sie unter
anderem einen fahrstuhl
aktuell haben sie 13 fortbewegungsmittel
benutzt die fahrt mit dem auto ist
nummer 14
von da oben sieht ihn ort genau wohin es
weitergeht
keynote probiert immer neue fahrzeuge
aus und holt auf bis jetzt haben sie
zwölf fortbewegungsmittel geschafft auch
dieses bobbycar haben sie sich kurz
ausgeliehen
team süd möchte gerne trocken am kölner
dom ankommen
dafür brauchen die drei einen fahrschein
doch für einen moment passen sie nicht
auf
team süd steigt eine station zu spät aus
und ist viel zu früh am dom
insgesamt haben sie sich auf 18
verschiedene arten durch köln bewegt
sogar zu dritt auf einem besen wagen
team nord denkt sich je kürzer die
strecke mehr fortbewegungsmittel sind
möglich
kurz vor dem dom haben sich erika
moderner und nicole auf mehr als 30
verschiedene arten fortbewegt auch mit
diesem bagger
und einem hubwagen und dann ist es
endlich soweit nach gut einer woche
treffen sich alle sechs kandidaten zum
ersten mal
wir wollten mit dem zug in der nähe vom
bahnhof fand sich der bericht in la
noire 12
ich glaube wir team ort gewinnt mit 30
fortbewegungsmitteln team süd hat nur 18
geschafft der aktuelle punktestand
lautet jetzt 7 zu 5 für team nord aber
die nächste haltestelle macht alle
wieder glücklich
berlin